A comedy's whole thing is that it's, well,
a comedy.
It's funny.
But for all the creative genius and careful
planning that goes into crafting a comedy
classic, filmmakers simply can't plan for
the happy little accidents that get caught
on film during the shooting of a movie.
Fortunately, those moments happen all the
time, and the best ones are usually even funnier
than the movies that spawned them.
"You like-a what you see-a"
Here are some bloopers that should have made
the final cut.
Superbad
A whole new generation got its very own iconic
nerd in Superbad.
He came in the form of McLovin, played by
Christopher Mintz-Plasse.
While he holds his own with Jonah Hill and
Michael Cera, one thing he couldn't hold his
own with was...a bee.
"F***, it's a bee!
Grow a set."
Then, when they're about to do another take,
Jonah Hill can't resist messing with him one
more time.
"It's right there dude."
"Alright.
Let's do another one."
That's what friends are for, right?
Guardians of the Galaxy
One of the funniest entries in the MCU, Guardians
of the Galaxy is hilarious in large part because
of Chris Pratt's casting as Star-Lord.
Pratt was known to improv on set, and some
of his on-the-fly bits stayed in the final
cut of Guardians.
And yet despite all the comedy that wound
up on screen, somehow the blooper of Pratt's
maniacal fake laughter is just as funny as
any line of dialogue that took weeks to fine-tune.
"Hahaha.
Anchorman 2
An endlessly quotable comedy classic, Anchorman
follows the absurd exploits of a 1970s San
Diego news team struggling to survive a changing
world.
In 2013, the cast returned for a sequel which
finds the Channel 4 News Team joining an upstart
cable news network in 1980.
Little else has changed, particularly Brian
Fantana, the sex-obsessed ladies' man portrayed
by Paul Rudd.
In the first movie, he shows off his collection
of toxic colognes.
"60% of the time it works every time."
"That doesn't make sense."
In the sequel, he updates the gag by unveiling
his condom collection, and the blooper reel
shows that he had plenty of jokes in the pipeline...if
he could get them out without laughing.
"In case you feel like smearing all over your
lady.
Go ahead, give her a pap smear.
That's horrible!"
Stay classy, Fontana!
The Hangover Part III
Like many film franchises,The Hangover franchise
suffered from diminishing returns.
The first film from 2009 captured lightning
in a bottle, and the filmmakers went back
to the same premise two more times.
In the first movie they went to Las Vegas,
in the second one they hit Bangkok, and in
The Hangover Part III the Wolfpack heads back
to Sin City.
"Phil, I think it's happened again."
But none of that's really important because
when Zach Galifianakis is part of a cast,
it doesn't matter what the plot is.
He's a one-man, snack-demanding Wolfpack both
in the film and on the gag reel.
"Mother food belly now."
"Mother fish sticks tater tots now please."
"Mother, hushpuppies and oreo smoothies now
please."
Step Brothers
Will Ferrell and John C. Reilly proved they
were among the best comedy duos of all time
in Step Brothers, playing stunted adult man-children
forced to get along when their coddling parents
marry each other.
Putting two agile comic minds on the s et
together day after day was bound to lead to
some improvisation…and cracking up.
And...wrestling?
"Come on!
NO!
No!"
"Say you're sorry!"
Deadpool
It was the role Ryan Reynolds was born to
play: a crude, sarcastic action hero with
absolutely no filter.
"Oh, your poor wife."
But a casting choice that worked just as well
was T.J. Miller as Wade Wilson's best friend
and bartender, Weasel.
Miller is a veteran stand-up comic and the
star of HBO's Silicon Valley, so it's no surprise
that when he sat down to spitball jokes about
Wade Wilson's new face, things got a little
weird.
"You look like an avocado that had sex with
an older avocado."
"Yeah."
In the blooper reel, Weasel just keeps the
jokes coming.
"You look like someone turned your face inside
out, and then just left it like that.
But then you got into a house fire."
"You look like the inside of other people's
a--holes."
"God, you look like a house fire was in another
house fire."
Harsh.
Trainwreck
It seems like whenever a big-time pro wrestler
moves into acting, people are genuinely shocked
by their abilities—but years and years of
performing in character for crowds certainly
trains them for the silver screen.
Case in point: John Cena, who had to act alongside
comedian Amy Schumer in Trainwreck.
Cena plays an enthusiastic romantic partner
to Schumer's character, and he's obviously
committed to the part...so committed that
he makes a pro comic like Amy Schumer crack
up non-stop during their sex scene.
"Maybe we can do it as a couple?
I'll be your coach?"
"I don't want you to be my coach..
You're an a**hole.."
Austin Powers in Goldmember
Early in Beyoncé's rise to world domination,
she mixed some acting in with her music career,
which included playing undercover spy Foxxy
Cleopatra in Mike Myers' third Austin Powers
outing.
Beyonce's beauty played well onscreen opposite
Austin Powers' rakish...uh, charm.
"Do I make you horny, baby?
Do I!
Do I make you Randy?"
She also served an important role as a straight
character for Powers' raunchy humor, a fact
displayed all too well in these outtakes:
"Tell me something I don't know."
"I can make my nipples wink."
"Say what?"
"Kangaroos make me horny."
"From time to time my nipples will lactate."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!